aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par malika rahal et grâce à son
travail
on va voir en quoi elle est le symbole
des bouleversements politiques en
afrique et au moyen orient
[Musique]
cette photo de nelson mandela a été
prise par le photo journaliste ammar
bouras à la coupole du 5-juillet à alger
en mai 1990
on dirait que c'est juste un portrait et
pourtant il montre l'un des
bouleversements historiques les plus
importants de notre siècle à l'époque ça
fait cinq mois que nelson mandela est
libéré de 27 années de détention en
afrique du sud
les images de sa libération font le tour
du monde et suscite une joie collective
dans les townships les quartiers pauvres
et rapidement il part pour une tournée
africaine
sur cette photo là l'air serein
peut-être un peu fatigué l'algérie c'est
important dans le parcours de nelson
mandela au maroc en 1962 alors qu'il
faisait une tournée dans plusieurs pays
pour y trouver du soutien
il s'est joint dans une base du front de
libération nationale algérien le fln il
reçoit un entraînement militaire
on était alors à la veille de
l'indépendance algérienne après une
guerre de plus de 7 ans cette guerre
c'est un modèle pour les
révolutionnaires du monde
le fln soutenait même concrètement les
différentes luttes anticoloniales
africaine et en juin 1962 au moment même
où l'algérie accédé à son indépendance
mandela revenus en afrique du sud il
était arrêté quelques semaines plus tard
le 5 août
en 1990 sa présence en algérie c'est
donc une réaffirmation de la solidarité
anti coloniale des années 1960 mais
d'après malika rahal l'histoire que nous
raconte la photographie ce n'est pas
seulement ça en fait à la fin des années
1980 l'ensemble du continent africain
connaît des bouleversements politiques
en quelques années plus de 30 pays
africains connaissent des transitions
politiques et abandonnent des régimes de
parti unique
ça bouillonne aussi au maghreb et au
moyen-orient en palestine rendue
présente ici par le caissier que porte
mandela la première intifada donc
révolte des jeunes armés de pierres
contre l'occupation israélienne dure
depuis 1987 mais l'algérie est alors le
seul pays d'afrique du nord à connaître
une réelle ouverture démocratique des
dizaines de partis politiques se créent
ainsi que des journaux privés pour
lequel travaille d'ailleurs le
photographe a marre bouras en cette fin
des années 80 c'est une période
d'ébullition de lutte enthousiasme de
manifestations culturelles et politiques
qui traversent alors le continent
africain et le monde arabe et c'est ça
que nous dit cette photo merci à malika
rahal qui nous a permis de faire cette
vidéo et à bientôt sur une image d'une
histoire
[Musique]